a California man dying of cancer just
appeared in court claiming a popular
weed killer made him sick in the first
case of its kind to reach trial dwayne
johnson ensuing Monsanto the maker of
Roundup the 46 year old blamed since
2014 cancer diagnosis on roundups active
ingredient glyphosate he's one of the
thousands of people nationwide
reportedly accusing Monsanto of failing
to quote exercise reasonable care to
warn of the dangerous risks associated
with use and exposure to glyphosate
Monsanto denies the allegations it says
in a statement to CBS News we have
empathy for anyone suffering from cancer
but the scientific evidence clearly
shows that glyphosate was not the cause
we look forward to presenting this
evidence to the court CBS News legal
analyst Ricky Clement is here with us
Ricky good morning morning what will
this case hang on let's look first at
the plaintiff and then we must look at
the defendant because this is going to
be a well tried and hard-fought case
with evidence on both sides the
plaintiff this is a singular plaintiff
because he is on the verge of death and
in California you can go first
so he is 46 years old he worked with
roundup for two years when he was a
groundskeeper he says three things
number one we have to look at the
scientific evidence and I the plaintiff
have been approved to you that this
chemical in roundup is what caused my
cancer number two that Monsanto
allegedly knew about this failed to warn
and also buried evidence about it for
the public and number three if they can
actually prove that which of course is
questionable if they can but if they can
then they're looking for punitive
damages Monsanto will have its own
mountain of data that they will put
forward saying that that government
agencies and other studies show that
glyphosate was safe and so what happens
with that
well Monsanto creates this battle of
experts and the literature is clearly on
monsanto side they have 800 studies
there was one study in particular that
came out of an agency out of the World
Health Organization in 2015 and it was
the one that said it was a
carcinogen and that was what spurred on
this litigation according to Monsanto
Monsanto says that the plaintiff science
is junk science but this judge is going
to let that science in now federal judge
who's looking at multi district
litigation he has said words like the
sciences loosey goosey from the
plaintiff and so Monsanto in those cases
may have a much better shot but
Johnson's attorney represents thousands
of other cancer patients right okay and
I think at least two thousand of the
let's count them four thousand you have
cases in San Francisco a mass of them
you have another mass of them in Saint
Louis where Monsanto is located those
cases or starting to go with those cases
in October so this is litigation that's
going to continue to continue but this
one's the bellwether because if in fact
this plaintiff wins that creates real
momentum for other plaintiffs and
Monsanto would have to rethink its
position however if this plaintiff loses
Monsanto is in a much better position to
discourage some of these other cases
that's why we'll continue to watch a
tricky claimant we will thank you so
much